-It's so nice to see you
in person.
-Yeah, yeah. It's really great
to be here.
-Thank you for being here.
-No problem.
-I want to get into everything.
I want to talk about the new
series, but I also follow you
on the socials, and I like to
follow you on there.
And you had a good -- Kind of
now and then you just
throw a throwback Thursday
photo, and I go,
"Oh, we should talk about that
next time."
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Next time you're on the show.
And you posted one on Instagram
of a "Mean Girls" karaoke party.
-I know. I thought that would --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I thought it was a good one.
-Lacey Chabert, Amy Poehler,
Lindsay Lohan.
I mean, that's a classic
right there.
-Also, it'd never been seen.
I thought I found gold
in my closet.
I was back in L.A., shooting
"The Dropout" and I was
going through all these pictures
trying to throw [bleep] away,
and I was just like,
"This is gold. We need to --"
-"Someone needs to see this."
-Yeah, this was my first
wrap party, and there was
karaoke with these fine folks.
-Do you do karaoke a lot?
-I don't.
-You do not, no.
-I don't like it.
-But you're a good singer.
I've heard you sing in movies.
-Thanks, I know.
I would do it for work.
I wouldn't want to ever force
people to listen to me.
Not on my watch,
you know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
-But that's the fun of karaoke.
We're all kind of paying
for entertainment from you,
from everybody.
-But some people take it
really seriously,
and then I feel like an idiot.
I'm too worried about what
people think of me.
So I will do, like, Eminem,
or I'll do something that's fun.
-You'll do something
that's kind of like,
"Don't take this serious."
-Yeah, yeah.
I'm definitely not good at this,
so therefore I'm going to do it.
-Oh, I'm the opposite.
-Are you competitive?
-I'm really trying to get
my album out.
[ Laughter ]
-Interesting.
-"Yo, if there's any producers
out there, check this out."
♪ Don't stop ♪
I'm going for it.
-But you can carry a tune, so
it's not -- It wouldn't be hard.
-Do you sing around the house?
-Yeah, I only sing things that
are stuck in my head,
which are like --
♪ Mira, Mira, Mira, Mira ♪
♪ Royal detective ♪
Or ♪ Hey, Gabby ♪
Does anybody know?
-Oh, yeah.
-♪ Welcome to the dollhouse ♪
-"Gabby's Dollhouse"
is the greatest. Come on.
-No, it's a great show,
and I love watching it.
I really do.
[ Laughter ]
-That is such funny reaction.
"No, I just love it so much!"
-I will tell you, I listened to
"Encanto" album
when I was in Barcelona --
away from my kids last week.
-Just 'cause you love it.
-Because I love it so much.
I do. I love it.
-You've been acting, believe it
or not, over 20 years.
Does that seem possible?
No.
-I don't --
-I don't believe that, yeah.
But I heard there was one job
early on that you missed out
on getting.
And I just want to hear
a little about this.
-Oh, good, the -- Yeah, I
auditioned for, like,
Clean & Clear and Neutrogena
and whatever else was there.
-You were just modeling first.
-Target commercial.
I really wanted to be part of
the Target commercials
because they were, like,
national commercials,
and you got paid a lot of money.
-Yeah, Target,
they make great commercials.
-Yeah, they do, and then make
you do weird stuff
in the auditions too.
-Like what?
-Like, "What's your
secret talent?" for instance.
And I was probably 15
or younger,
and they put on some
Timberlake song.
And I was like,
"I'm not going to dance,
but I can do the robot."
[ Laughter ]
That's another thing.
This is very related to my fear
of, like, singing.
I'll just rap for you.
You want me to dance?
I'm not going to dance for you,
but I'll do the robot.
You know what I mean?
-Okay, yeah, so you don't dance,
you don't sing, but you do,
though, sing, in real life.
I've heard you in movies.
-Yeah, for -- Yeah.
-Yeah. And then robot comes out
when what, under pressure?
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
-Like weddings or something?
You're like, "Don't make me --
I don't really want to --"
So what if a beat just came on
right now, what would happen?
-Uh...
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I guess I would get up
and I would try to do the robot.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You committed to
that first one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you do it.
Oh, my gosh.
You really commit to it.
-Thanks. It's hard.
-You're very good.
-I love that you did that.
You really commit to it.
By the way, you're getting
amazing reviews
for your role in "The Dropout."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. It's a dream.
-Amanda Seyfried in
"a career-best performance,"
"Chicago Sun Times,"
not too shabby.
Career-best, wow.
I mean, you're fantastic.
-I guess I'm done.
-"Spell-binding performance,"
"Sydney Morning Herald."
I mean, "terrifyingly
mesmerizes,"
"Hollywood Insider."
I mean, this is a big deal.
-It's so crazy.
-Did you think the voice was
going to be the thing?
Did you think,
"Oh, I could just do her"?
Did you see the documentary?
How did you get into it?
-I did it all.
I also had deposition tapes of
just a static camera on her
while she's being questioned
from the SCC.
-Fascinating character.
-Yeah, and you see a lot.
I mean, you see everything
in those tapes.
And I also did a lot of watching
every YouTube video
that was ever recorded of her
on stage.
And, you know, of course,
I watched everything
and listened to everything --
the Carreyrou book on Audible
and "The Dropout" podcast,
of course, which this is
based on.
Man, I couldn't get enough.
It was the most fun ever.
And you know what?
A bunch of my actor friends
were like,
"God, you're a character actor."
And I was like, "I never thought
of it that way."
It's so much more fun to play
people that are
a little bit separate
from who you are.
I'm always playing a version of
myself, right?
And I love it.
And I'm good at it, depending.
And this was just a completely
different ballgame,
and I really loved it.
-And is it true that -- 'Cause I
remember the documentary,
watching that, and then going
like -- A lot of her friends
were like, "Yeah, that kind of
really was never her voice."
And then her eyes
just started --
She just started not blinking.
She read that in some book
like if you blink,
it's sign of weakness
or something.
-Yeah, something like that.
Like, you're not listening
or like just really,
I'm invested in you.
I want to know
what you're saying.
-So she would just not blink,
and she would come and just
stare and not blink.
And I was like, "Oh, my gosh,
it's fascinating."
And you kind of nailed it.
You really did a great job.
-[ as Elizabeth Holmes ]
You got to get there, you know?
It's really important.
[ Normal voice ] No, sorry.
It's not that deep.
Listen, it's my version.
I always have to remind people
it's my version of it.
I will never be able to go
that low,
but I will go as low as I can
with the affect.
-You did. Perfect.
Yeah. Don't change.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Amanda Seyfried in the
series finale of "The Dropout."
Take a look at this.
-You're just smearing it in.
Give it to me.
I think I'm very angry at you.
I am.
I'm very angry.
-You told me that when you
visited me at school,
after everything that happened,
you told me to just put it away
and forget it.
If you choose to forget
certain things,
do you think that's lying?
-Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Amanda Seyfried, everybody!
-Such good writing.
-The series finale of
"The Dropout"
airs this Thursday on Hulu.
Amanda and I are doing
the whisper challenge
when we come back.
Stick around, everybody.